good morning or whatever time of day it
is when you're watching this video I
realize that it's been two weeks since I
last uploaded a let's play video so
there's actually quite a lot that I need
to talk about basically the reason why i
haven't uploaded a let's play videos
because I just haven't worked on the
pike which i haven't done because I
really well I really wanted to not work
on this bike if I didn't have any
inspiration or good ideas of what I
wanted to do and I didn't have any of
that so in the meantime I've worked on
many different projects some of which
you might see soon or you've already
seen if you're watching this video in
the future or may already see in any
case as an ex-con coaster coming up
which is pretty much finished I still
need to make the music in the video for
it and I was also a collaboration with
someone which is going to be fun I don't
know when I'm going to release those
things but that's basically what I've
worked on and what you should what
should appear sometime soon on the
channel and this morning I bought parka
texts that's really awesome it's a
really awesome game you don't know it
yet go check it out you really need to I
mean of course a compromise any but
everybody will like it but I like the
game and I finally picked it up I really
got it from someone a long time ago but
I really just wanted to buy it as well
and I might actually want to make some
videos on that in the near future but
first I really want to practice on it i
don't know i don't share videos of me
sucking that's one game so and there's
that and i think i do have to talk about
the let's play park as well basically
the thing that I wanted to do next in
this bike was to actually work on the
paths and buildings in this area and
make the big force and that is all
connected to the dark ride something I
don't know what sort of dark round it's
gonna be but it's gonna be a ignition I
cried and I probably do want to theme it
around you know some of those some of
those really dark sinister England
things and it's hard to explain
something like the London Underground
it's I think fun to make a dark right
off as well so that's something that I
want to do with this area and really
before I didn't really have a good idea
of what I wanted to do with this area
but I've actually looked at some Chester
mock tudor buildings and figured that's
what I sort of want to try another's one
thing which I still really need to say
that's that I don't have any experience
whatsoever when it comes to to do
buildings and when it comes to an
English theme in general and to be very
honest I've barely even seen image
themes made in this game ever so if
there's any British people were not even
British people out there but just people
who know stuff about British
architecture and it turns out that my
architecture completely sucks and it's
unrealistic don't worry to tell me that
my building suck because I kind of need
that feedback to you know kind of be
sure that where I am going is actually a
good direction and speaking of the
direction in which I'm building you'll
probably see a lot of me placing
buildings and then removing them
afterwards and placing other stuff and
just try on the error all over the place
with this theme because like I said I'm
really just unexperienced with it with
this team and I just need to practice
with it usually I would have practiced
outside the theme outside this Pike not
recording and then get into the park and
see what I can do with that but this
time I just decided to be bold and go
straight into it which you might also
notice by how unexperienced I seem in
some of my buildings and I don't know
why the screen is standing still at the
moment that's also some of the things
what the hell was I doing over here that
was probably some stream issue yawn the
next couple the next couple of episodes
are at least partly recorded in streams
which is my might sometimes for a few
seconds be just completely nothing
happening sometimes I just need to check
the chat stuff like that so I'm sorry
about that as well in any case I figured
that right from here from this Brad
first floating thing up until the dark
ride facade I want to have one big
string of bagel city buildings with some
good mock tudor architecture but this
one is more of a almost factory ish more
high brick building I'm really not too
sure how realistic it's gonna be but to
me at least the most important factors
into making this entire string of
assaults look English is it
definitely in the textures and in the
chimneys and the textures because I
really want to get some of those weather
down English looking brick textures that
orange you know very clean looking but
you know dirty and stuff because that's
what singlet and that's what England's
like at least that's what I feel with
look English and definitely some
chimneys because they're very very
prominent on English architecture and
then of course is the smaller stuff like
you know Victorian fences and Victorian
posted everywhere and listening to the
beatles and bloor while I'm building the
buildings i'm sure those nuts gonna help
at least that's what i've done hopefully
helps ah and yeah this was actually my
first try it's doing a timber building
hey I mock Tudor building i should say
and i had to redo this structure a
couple of times because one of the main
issues that i had and this was actually
some feedback that I got from comments
and later reflected oh that's actually
true is the fact that when you have to
the buildings like this what usually
happens is that the second floor even
the third floor hangs over so each floor
kind of hangs over the one below it and
that's one that's something that I
didn't really have in the tutor
buildings that I tried before so
something that I definitely wanted to
get in here so that is why the second
floor sticks out half a tile from the
first floor the only problem that I have
with an entire thing his stats is
brother kosuke three and you can move
half a tile but the problem that I sort
of had with this is that sticking out
hospitals a lot like it's it would have
been better if I could get the second
floor it actually stick out a quarter
tile but yeah that's something that
can't happen in roller coaster can three
so I'm kind of [ __ ] in that regard and
pretty much stuck with what I have and
here was a lot of messing with the roof
because I wanted to get those those
strings of pointy boobs that you often
see into the building's if if you know
you've kind of have an image of what to
the buildings are like you probably
understand why I mean you got all these
very little sort of dormer things on the
roof and that's what I wanted to have
over here but actually took quite a
while to actually get them right
the roofs in general were a bit of an
issue because as you may know there
aren't any English custom scenery sets
but you can usually still get the stucco
and brick walls with different sets and
I've already made some brick walls for
the Dutch area that actually sort of fit
this but the roofs are a bit of an issue
so far only station Jim's country in
roof is one I think really fits and
other than that I haven't really found
any roof that I like a lot and think
that it fits very well that's a bit of
an issue as well but otherwise I think
actually at alpine village in this is
very very handy the majority of these
buildings are alpine village just good
old wooden posts and good old stucco
walls but now everything is white and
black and that should pretty much loot
make it look tutor enough I'm sure
there's actually some realism things
that I'm still missing out on and if I
do don't hesitate to tell me but I'm
really only going towards a certain
extent I like to think that this is
still a theme park and a theme park is
not going to be a one hundred-percent
perfect copy of a certain style at least
and that is not the case if I look into
the theme park such as Europa pike so
yeah let's it's sort of why I do want to
kind of find the freedom between doing
what I want and just making some fantasy
theme park sort of facades and finding
that sort of realism that at least you
can recognize what sort of country
episod is in by looking at it ecstatic
that should always be clear that's my
main sort of at least thing that I went
to have for these buildings it was
actually a bit of overlap I found that
interesting because obviously if for
making these facades I looked into a
number of English cities and kind of
looked like looked at what they were
like and actually found a couple of
buildings that sort of blended into each
other they would have liked it you would
for example have a Tudor building with a
brick building next to it and then one
part of the Tudor building which sort of
blend into the brick building have one
floor which is still to do something
like that which is also something that I
kind of wanted to have in this string of
massage because there's definitely a
different style to each building
but I still wanted them to mix in a tiny
bit as that's white kind of experiments
it with that and otherwise pretty much
every building the second floor is
sticks out Harper tile and that's pretty
much the rules that I try to follow with
this facade one important thing is
actually that I still don't have too
much of an idea of what i'm going to do
with the inside I think that's for these
buildings that I have so far that these
are going to be there a gift shop just
one gift shop because obviously these
for science on their owner way too small
for one gift shop so I think I'm just
gonna make this entire string one big
gift shop and then the buildings next to
this as well as the building of the dark
ride itself should have the queue inside
of it sort of in a long and underground
sort of way at least that's the current
planning I am definitely still planning
to actually get some sort of interiors
in and i'm not sure what sort of
interiors I want to do but I really
can't ignore it and he'll that's toilet
of course I should get toilet in
somewhere and probably a gift shop and
probably a queue and this is going to be
a dog run anyway so that sort of counts
as an interior and so that those are the
things that I definitely still want to
get in although on the topic of toilets
I still haven't really got the toilet
sets and that's something that I still
need to install but as soon as I get
that I'll probably make some toilets in
the park finally other than just taking
a random building and slapping toilet
signs on to it because that seems like a
very lazy approach to doing it although
another thing that I do have to say
against that is the more I build in this
park the more i am not certain if i can
actually do it or in this park actually
get some questions still about this so
really i just to clarify my clerk my
current plan is to finish this half of
the park in this Pike file and then copy
the main street and bring it into
another Pike file and finish the other
half of the park in a different park
file the only issue is that so far I
have built about one-third of the park
rather than while fifty percent of it
and it's already over 13 mb and it's
lagging in
all mostly you don't notice it in the
time up since it is you know sped up but
the lank is pretty bad and even though
this isn't an issue in the time lapse it
is an issue for me building this Pike
sometimes especially when you have a
mouse leg and build leg I don't know if
it's called build leg it probably isn't
like placement leg no idea what to call
it but basically sometimes the mouse
sort of lags behind which means that you
accidentally place a piece on the wrong
well a wrong placement for example you
just get hme and you try to build it
somewhere but your mouth legs behind I
mean your cursor likes behind with where
your mouth is going accidentally placed
the chimney somewhere else and stuff
like that pretty annoying and sometimes
it just takes a couple milliseconds for
the game to actually register that I do
a Maps click and then I want to play
something and for example click the
mouse to place a chimney but it places a
couple of milliseconds later and this
isn't too big of an issue if you're just
placing one object but if you're trying
to build a building and connects also
two pieces to each other really fast it
starts becoming really annoying really
fast as well and there is of course also
the problem mats at some point in roller
coaster is just going to give up
actually loading this park and that's
what I'm most afraid of as soon as
actually starts crushing and I started
having really big issues that you know I
can't open the park anymore I can't
place anything anymore that's what I
want to avoid it all costs so I'm gonna
try to keep going with the spike as long
as I can but I'm really starting to
doubt whether I can keep going with a
spike for a very long time looking at
how bad it's already starting to become
but then again I don't like to worry
about that yet i'll just see whenever
this goes anyway this was sort of the
basic planning of the facades by the way
don't worry about me placing not none of
the details actually still placed on
these buildings it was a bit of planning
more so than adding details already so
and just kinda wanted to get this force
on out there to see what i wanted it to
look like but really i'm going to add
the details actually finish up these
buildings in the next three or so
episodes in any case I see that I'm out
of time so thank you for watching and
I'll see you guys in a neck
episode Pete's source of prestige now
you can keep it at work I'll be the same